good morning everyone
good morning sister you can't do this to
me today because I'm in equally bad
shape as I say I'm just being dramatic
I'm pretty fine Pedialyte is life and
I'm broken but I'm fine I'm doing okay
yeah like I'm fine I'm fine enough to be
here like I'm not suffering from one of
my signature hangovers but I'm not great
and what I really need is sleep and the
toast took that away from me this what I
really need it's not even like the
hangover I have a sty and a sore throat
and like I don't know what to do about
it that here this sexy recipe knows time
heals Oh guys and sore throats also
talking about it heals it yeah talking
about it's fun complaining about it is
even better um anyways we are dead
through scenes because the Hyland's a
banger of a night we had like a classic
night do you know any me had a classic
us night they don't happen like so often
where it's just like the stars align
yeah and the Bravo Liberty is alive
thing like you invited to like all these
like fake events all the time and they
always say like oh this person's going
this person's going like you show up and
it's terrible I'm like I'm so like of
the mindset now like I don't go to
anything I'd rather miss out on the one
good event then go to 100 and like
they're all be terrible you know yeah
these events you guys like you don't
even know it's just like the future so
me and Jackie all day were planning on
going to the OK Magazine summer kick-off
party and then at like 6 o'clock the
craziest storm started in New York like
out of nowhere the sky was black and it
was wild and then we're like we're not
going like we like we took it as a sign
we're definitely nobody else's
Garlington party's canceled yeah it was
outdoors so we're like whatever we're
like laying I order dinner
I keep facetiming Claudia because I'm
like the annoying one that's like
Claudia we really should go I don't want
to go and like please Mitch I'm not
going but I was like we probably should
go so these but then this storm started
to see this swarming Webster came though
we started to see the OK Magazine
Instagram stories like actually cool
people were there somewhere like we let
her got dressed in 20 minutes I've never
gotten dressed so quickly in my life
because like it was just luck you know
right so we got there like it was very
interesting like how like the housewives
were split up with the Dallas girls
we're all together and they were with a
girl who I'm pretty sure as the new
Dallas House but she
pretty and they were just like they had
their own teeth like a click Sonia was
like on one side of the party like with
her crew and like all the other house
with New York housewives we're on the
other side but eventually Sonia came
over I know she didn't show a different
woman oh so it was phony Forgan it was
interesting so like and then the other
New Yorkers right
Tinsley drinka were together who else
was there in New York I'm Sonja was
separate so it was just weird like shut
day and then our table which was I think
the most lit one we were with New Jersey
we were with Margot Joseph and Melissa
Morgan who is an angel from God both of
them like I want to like I want them to
be my mom like I love them I love that
and we we have a really a possible
special project coming up with melissa
gorga my still in the works we came up
with the idea for it last night but I'm
money you know we're gonna make it
happen mate we're gonna make another if
this comes to fruition I want you to
know it's going to be the most epic
unbelievable top tier piece of content
on the internet today I'm so excited
about it anyways so it's just so
interesting how we had our pick of all
the house I sort of oh and Penny
Mellencamp was there oh you guys just as
your Teddy Mellencamp for the things
that we say about her because of how she
behaves like a house in Beverly Hills go
in but Emily says good things know but
we just did her character but like and
we've always said that in person she was
so nice she was so nice when she came on
our show last night
another angel she couldn't have been no
no no no she was so funny and cool and
she brought like her six mom friends to
the party and they were having the best
time it was awesome I like her and it's
just such a shame that I can't that
Teddy IRL and Teddy TV alright Wow it's
better to be better IRL
I guess that how many people actually
get to meet you know but like this is
what everyone was saying it was like
she's literally the nicest coolest girl
like that doesn't make for interesting
TV right like my screen versions of
people like Ramona like Sonja like uh
I'm getting water for you know Hank I
have water I have a cold
is that my bottle no that's mine oh okay
I don't have that okay my water bottle
I'm telling you like I'm just having so
I've got these two relatable or more the
TV but I love
nonetheless but it's crazy after having
like the pic of every city of housewives
we are Housewives of New Jersey because
what a thunk they're the most lit first
of all yeah second of all they like us
the best like New York is like a little
clicky like they wouldn't being like
open tossed around for like so long and
again and this is their City yeah yeah
the Dallas girls like couldn't even
sweeter like we're having the time of
their lives
yeah and Phaedra was there which we
didn't get to like we the points guy is
really good friends with Phaedra and I
was like wishing the points guy was
there so like he can introduce me to her
like you met her but like not enough to
like be friendly you never know I heard
a very memorable look so me and Jackie
were being like we honestly like we said
to ourselves on this show we were like
we're not thirsty as like as thirsty as
we should be we need to be thirsty
randomly instead of the year of free
stuff like I think first needs to come
the year first so you know what we
channeled our inner thirst last night
and like we were like hearing whispers
about like what was like going on
afterwards and it turns out that like
everyone decided to go to cats for
dinner so we tagged along on Melissa and
Margaret's reservation and then like we
just kept inviting people so like Steve
gold from million dollar listing came
with his assistant I think Jessica her
name is who's also on the show sometimes
and like wait you guys he affirmed he's
not dating Brittany it's justice for
Steve gold he we met him we were talking
to him earlier we were like we're
literally talking about you this morning
because you're dating brittny Gastineau
and he was like that's not true he was
like I know her a house in st. Lucia
like that's it
and another way I did that we told him
that we would tell you that it's not
true
and he posted to his Instagram story
yesterday like don't believe everything
you read I no longer believe anything I
read and by the way I don't think TD
does him like half the amount of justice
as it should because he is one of the
the hottest guys alive like I was living
for him and like honestly I think he was
living for me too sure I think TV does
do him justice Selleck everyone thinks
that he's hot like he's no for sure I
never thought he was on to us on the
person oh I think he's like universe and
he's like so sweet and like it's like a
nice smile he is a sweetie yeah so he
came in joining us Stephen Magee came
and then carried uber she left Brandi
and Stephanie and went with Teddy
Mellencamp to catch and they had dinner
next to us with all of Teddy's mom
friends and it was just like if I was a
parent right now with the new Dallas
House my
oh and guess who walked in wait I'll
give you a clue give me a clue doggers
she buys her a September summer she bag
gucci spring semester i walked in i
guess she was also bad the okay magazine
party
i saw a picture from instagram later but
i didn't see her at the party and then
we saw her and like it was literally
like seeing like santa like god like
yeah I was like joggers I didn't get to
talk to her or say anything to her but
like I just really that's like the one
thing person I wish I infiltrated last
night yeah and then also that Real
Housewives of Potomac who legit thought
she was Lisa Vanderpump oh my god you
should have seen this [ __ ] walking
walking at her couch like legit she not
Lisa Rinna but she thought she was like
Jennifer Lawrence
she thought everyone in the restaurant
was looking at her she's like she was
Jennifer Lopez
I don't watch Potomac I don't know her
name but she was really pissing me off I
think her name is Ashley I don't know
though whatever like about which is the
patron I catch last night like I would
have died like I know your favorite
house i socked in had your favorite
influencers and morning show host right
it was just like so crazy
the only person also I wish that was
there that wasn't was Laura more kiss
she had stuck in the Bronx I don't know
how and C gonna make it oh right but I
really just want to meet her because
like I think I would like her
really and I wanna get invited to some
summer house parties oh my god we have
to yeah I think Taylor's record yes
that's the funniest thing ever know that
she's thanks for our level of thirst I
think in order to reach the next level
we need to get in the background of a
Bravo show we almost got on Beverly
Hills oh I'm sorry we were on Beverly
Hills and I was in the background of a
restaurant with a New York right right
so right we're there [ __ ] that's pretty
okay but maybe we'll get a line yeah
totally
I'm Anton Kyle were there too and we're
friendly is she with them I think Lauren
work it's like she could really be our
ticket in I mean I got invited to what
that party that tellest record but I was
like I'm not driving to watermill and
now I'm like I wish I was I would have
gotten in there with no stranger well
the great stop when we weren't going
last night I kept it was like okay we're
not going but like I don't want you to
feel like I'm stopping you and I'm like
I'll email the girl and tell her you're
bringing Zach like I just like please
like don't put this on me and we're
trying to put it on no because it was on
you know but you could've won without
really you worse having me easy I'm
gonna go without you yes it's a package
to you know
she'll so she was like girl let me stop
you I'm like no no you have stopped me
this has been the great stop of 2018
we'll never forget this moment of the
great stops it seems like you have other
great stops in your life oh my god for
sure like I am my biggest great style so
are you my biggest adversary like if
there's so many places like I just
should have went and like didn't go dude
do you know yeah and do you like have do
you lead a life of regret ever
oh look about one thing but kW Beauty
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] she was invited to
the k'kaw Beauty launch someone that was
in Kim's home and she and the one where
Kim posted pictures of everyone and the
influencer you would have been on Kim's
Instagram Herk Instagram and that's
again you learned realized it was in LA
I got two days notice you can book a
flight in an hour you could go you could
leave this studio and get on a flight to
LA just it could happen good I coulda
woulda shoulda
guys please don't be fooled I know you
would think that it is cuz this is such
a prestigious show but we are not
sponsored by Poland Spring what's it
called Poland Spring and I was growing
up I thought it was Oland spring because
the pee is so weird oh it's like cool
and spring I love Poland Spring it is
called Poland Spring but I'm like how is
it Poland like it's wait Poland like the
country wait no it's like it's from a
it's made for the Northeast I was about
to say I feel like it's only a New York
thing but it's no it's Northeast I've
been growing up to new poems bring my
whole life and I never realized it had
the country Poland in the title but it
has nothing to do with that's holy
you're looking at it now right Oland
it's cuz it's from Poland Spring main oh
and or cold spring Denmark means how do
I know it's just how are they in Denmark
in Poland so why am i drinking Poland
Spring if it could be from the rain how
international are we
Cheers okay
so what some into the past five stories
that you need to know before you make up
an take about that anymore t-test yes
because we need to pre sue this summit
because some of us need to get back okay
first story am Al Clooney angered
fashion designer Tom Ford's team after
wearing her backup outfit by a different
designer on the Met Gala red carpet
saving his red stained glass gown for
the private after-party a de Sade
to see the stained glass gown oh I'm
saying big mistake but you in the
picture sorry guys sorry I didn't see oh
nice oh my god re cathedral and it's
literally gorgeous no one's like being
like why are you wearing prepare this
one because Jacob is graduating Kaiser
grab Oh turning oh wait this is what she
did we're business in the front party in
the back you know very modern woman
pants suit with a little bit of skirt in
the back skirt skirt and by a little I
mean a lot of skirt are we seeing it
great okay yeah now this is what she was
supposed to wear on the red carpet but
wound up wearing to an after-party made
by Tom Ford inspired by the stained
glass windows of the control of
Catholicism yeah
well that jacket gorgeousness gorgeous I
think I like this better
of course it's so but like it's not like
a WoW it'll sound like a big train and
it's like it's a safe choice
let me see there but I feel like when
you wear your backup dress it's because
you don't feel comfortable in your in
your real dress maybe it was too much of
a risk maybe it's too tight maybe like
you know you're you had a big lunch yeah
like how was she gonna wear that dress
that she wore in the red carpet to an
after-party you're supposed to be like
most people change it's like a mini
dress yeah and like 'mom Clooney goes to
after parties a plea doesn't she have
like justice to serve no doesn't she
have human rights to to protect to
oversee she has human rights to protect
you guys like I don't know what she's
doing at the after party maybe she just
wanted this used to wear this dress I
love her and I love my dress more but
this seems like a big mistake huge this
would have been a no-brainer winner
yes dressed like at the other dress I
think she looks great but like you Diego
so it was it was a controversial look
for someone who's chairing the gala it's
always good to have a controversial look
when you're cheering oh yeah what kind
of guy oh it's a regatta gala I actually
think I've seen every episode of friends
know you have and by the way so many
show I'm in like so Marie I've just
finished I rewatched it on a loop so now
I'm like back at the bee
and I'm in a moment in season 3 where
it's like all the best episodes one
after the other it's the one it's my
stinky shoes what about this recipe what
is a magic oblate that's coming up soon
but then it's um
then it's 18 pages front and back you
fell asleep
and you already found out today we
haven't obviously our big toasters group
which is really popping and you should
join it but we have like a spin-off
group that's like a friend's obsessed
group and you want I don't know that
friends on Netflix it's like a cut-down
version of the episode like they
sometimes cut out jokes so like if
you're watching on Netflix and I've
really only seen friends like on Netflix
and then like run on some TV every runs
on TV like some of the episodes are cut
like some of the jokes aren't there
that's so easy I've seen it I should get
the DVD yeah no oranges fight on Amazon
I wanted to do it that's the TV Cup well
that's like when you watch movies on TV
and they take out all the best jokes
it's like someone needs to ask me like
what lines they can take out of Legally
Blonde because the ones that they're
taking out it's unacceptable you're like
hey Jackie what could we do that
yeah like and what must stay I just
discovered Jennifer Coolidge's Instagram
Claudia I was gonna say the same thing
really one must have send it to both of
us yeah where she's trying to talk to
Siri yeah you know and then just like
her Instagram in general is completely
epic and everyone chahbahar
Julie's like 160k like eight it's good
but like I need more you know yeah it's
like it's accidentally good and I need
someone to really just hone in on this
and this really cool didn't nugget in
moments okay
next story cardi B sparks a chaotic
locks Las Vegas mall fight after
allegedly ignoring a fan who asked for a
selfie um
she's pregnant what are you fighting for
II a chaotic scene ensued after cardi B
allegedly ignored fans asking for a
selfie in a Las Vegas mall last month oh
this was a month ago like why are we
talking like the Delano just reporting
why is the toaster Daily Mail homepage
today I don't know it's cause like they
don't tell you stuff until they want you
to know I'm sorry Cristiano releases its
she's setting up for something the
pregnant invasion of privacy rapper was
caught in a shouting match with a woman
who the blast identified as Lolita
Beckford Dawkins in a now viral video of
the incident which took place April 25th
shortly after the video
spread the New Yorkers shared now
deleted tweets about what went down
while also explained that she's not
obligated to take photos with fans
especially in her delicate condition I
really this is such a [ __ ] story she
admitted to shouting [ __ ] cardi you
ain't [ __ ] but the card so that's just
false
of me ghost rapper offset and after the
star allegedly ignored her
people are [ __ ] nuts the videos I'm
popular nuts and like honestly like I
feel like anytime someone asks me for a
photo I'm like so grateful for it that
like I'm lovely but people take things
the wrong way all the time for example
when I was in San Francisco I had an
event and they did a contest on my
Instagram I like one of people to come
so I let three people who live in the
area like just like all your to do was
like like this photo and like you would
submit and I chose these three girls and
they came in the best time in like it
was my event so like they had like open
bar they could order on my table I was
there from 8 to 10 I ended up staying
till 11 cuz it was like such a fun party
this girl gets her a 10:30 party's over
I shouldn't even be there anymore I'm
all this was to be there till 10 she
comes at 10:30 and I'm like on my way
out I'm like saying about everyone I'm
like hi oh my god took a picture it's
like here sit order whatever you want I
gave her my french fries literally like
she sent me the nastiest message about
how like I'm the meanest person she's
ever met she couldn't have been more
disappointed in meeting someone like me
like she expected me be so different I'm
like dude what the [ __ ] are you talking
about I'm like no by the time you see I
hadn't even supposed to be there like
the event went on till like midnight but
I was always opposed to be there from
8:00 to 10:00 that everyone got really
should like strict instructions like
Claudia's there from 8:00 to 10:00 I
stay till 11:00 cuz I was having such a
good time so like thank God I even saw
her like I'm sure and made me feel so
bad and so guilty she was like I would
actually find this message she was like
like I'm so disappointed like you're
like all the famous gone to her head I'm
like [ __ ] please like I wish she was so
[ __ ] rude and I was it she made me
feel so guilty and I was like you know
what you really like literally can't see
a table you can't satisfy everyone now
you can't say any in Andy's books he
talks about that all the time because
like he really does like me every show
he does every AC live like every book
reading like it's so much meet and greet
with like you know his followers like
yentas like old Jewish ladies and like
there's tell obnoxious and they just
want to like talk and he's like
sometimes I just can't and like she's
like sometimes like I snap or like and
of course like the person who it it's
like always rants about it on Twitter
and like
a million people you know and it's like
celebration people - yeah that's sweet
um especially pregnant celebrities yeah
no no that's like a whole other level
like I would never go up to a pregnant
celebrity no but remember that girl who
came up to us last night and was like
you guys look so different in person
oh yeah we were in the bathroom and
Jagger pain she comes up to us and she's
like oh my god like I love the to
somewhere like thanks and it's like you
guys look so different in person we're
like how is that even possible
we're like more beautiful right okay
where how's that possible like first all
the toasts like we look like we look
like potatoes how kids hide from this
camera and then it's like okay maybe
like our Instagram photos are filtered
and nothing but like our stories like
yeah I just and you can't escape it a
toast like you guys know everything like
this is this is it we don't use a
stretcher
we can't live street like we can't live
so you are stretching out for yeah I
wish we could
that's crazy people who stretch their
videos yeah no that's why other people
will do anything what isn't about people
will go so far to not be seen like how
they really are people will go so far
not to just diet and exercise no meet
you but like actually you know that's
100% mean like I would rather legit get
kybella ambien the most pain ever and
have it possibly not work then even
think about diet or exercise there's no
way you're getting high Bella no I'm a
hundred percent decided against it yeah
I just heard so much negative feedback
about a the pain and the results it's
like if it's that painful but you really
look amazing like it's worth it
people are like I don't even see a
difference [ __ ] no one and here's the
problem for you you have to do it twice
so after the first time it's so painful
you don't see a difference you will not
go back from the second time therefore
there's no point it's just like a little
bit like you had your Judy Claudia and
this SS say that Margo's at jury duty
today
and she made a poop I just think that's
a funny anecdote like you should at jury
duty like good for you but this is yeah
take advantage use all their 12 favorite
a steal yeah take some 12 Abram that's
how you beat the system my friend Jenna
had Jerry Judy with Donald Trump like
before he was running for president like
he was just a citizen of New York is
that crazy that's crazy picture I've to
ask report people are saying I saw you
guys at Robin Hood at the Robin Hood
event and you look exactly the same
I
but like is that a compliment no wait
also we're deaf shorter in person I get
that all the time we said last night I
was wearing 6-inch heels ya know
especially when people used to come
first to end Fridays and like we don't
wear heels for the show we're like just
little women running around odes up and
I see people were really shocked at how
short we are and that is true we are
very short if you ever meet us you will
be surprised yeah by the way I really do
you can finance I want you but like no I
think we could do five chairs five
people at a time and like we're gonna
have to charge them because you know
this the show doesn't pay for itself
right and like the five chairs we're
gonna have to buy our kind of pay yeah
what kind of chair so you guys won
folding chairs I think folding chairs
because not every Friday what like not
every day is a fan ride or you know what
we actually should do what Andy does is
I think they keep some of the profits
but they also donate some of it to
charity we should go that's that's nice
we should do that okay oh you know what
hit us up on GM's about like good
organizations Robin Hood Oh actually
really is a really good organization but
you know what they have enough money
they have so much literally this
organization was so rich I couldn't
believe that I'm like this organization
does indeed money I be money for this
organization they do amazing work that I
didn't know much about me neither other
than it's called Robin Hood so they
steal from the rich to give to the poor
which is like a funny name but I didn't
know like really the level of work that
they do and that it's New York specific
so like the money is so targeted and
they use like business practices like
algorithms and data in order to inform
like where they're gonna allocate funds
it's like all very smart I donated when
we were there same I was just like so I
was so impressed you know and they have
like great content creation like the way
they does their videos like they called
this guy Jose who like grew up in the
Bronx and was like going down a dark
path but he found Robin and he became a
teacher now he like educates people who
dropped out of high school and want to
get their GED or go to college and it
was this video like obviously the work
he does was amazing but this video was
like inspiring like that means the music
and you know like they get the music
rights whatever they want Oprah just
saying makes a call Oprah sir Oprah was
there we didn't even talk about Oprah I
know we were like kind of far from her
but like she gave a speech I was a 90%
sure she didn't have a teleprompter and
like I don't really remember what she
said but I remember just being like so
motivated to like do more and yeah the
way that she speaks ISM is motivating
it's almost like she practiced for 25
years
watch The Oprah Winfrey Show it's like a
little bit before our time yeah but like
apparently was epic and the people just
like run home from school to watch it I
wish they were born like a few years
before but then we'd be like older now
we'd be like 30 no but sometimes I wish
that I wasn't born like in the digital
age like that you were born earlier you
know that like maybe I started using
social media like in my 20 it's not like
in my teens but then you wouldn't have
started using social media and you
wouldn't have success of it that's true
this you would have been like a dinosaur
okay what's the next door okay this next
story I just clicked because it looks
interesting because did you see Kim
Kardashian posted an ad with a little
flat tummy appetite suppressing
lollipops and I swear I was literally
gonna bat go buy one except I figured if
it definitely doesn't work right yeah it
was a good idea but Kim Kardashian has
been branded a quote terrible and toxic
influenced by Jameela Jamil as she leads
the backlash against reality stars
appetite suppressant ad oh my god
there's backlash against this ad yeah
like so much and this one influencers
like spearheading it oh my god where
have I been
oh sorry I was having the time of my
life yeah okay magazine party Kim
Kardashian has faced huge backlash for
promoting an appetite suppressing
lollipop the reality star 37 shared a
snap of herself tucking into the treat
on Instagram and encouraged her 111
million followers to purchase a product
in order to aid weight loss however the
post was immediately met with criticism
with presenter Jameela Jamil branding
came a terrible and toxic influence for
failing to promote healthy eating what
the controversial snap sees a seemingly
naked Kim stuck me on the red well I pop
up for the camera of course daily
managed sexual done weight proving to be
a fan of the diet sweet she wrote okay
we all saw it
this is what jameelah said no I think
that says [ __ ] off because it's blurred
out I'm gonna assume because its blur
off no blur off you terrible and toxic
influence on young girls I admire their
mothers branding capabilities she isn't
exploitive but innovative genius however
this family makes me feel actual despair
over what women are reduced to maybe
don't take appetite suppressors and eat
enough to fuel your brain and work hard
and be successful and to play with your
kids and to have fun with your friends
and to have something about your
something to say about your life at the
end other than I had a flat stomach
honestly I'm so done with the criticism
of the Kardashians because here's why
first of all they've never claimed to be
anything other than what they are
don't come looking at them for being bad
role models like their whole thing
started with a sex tape they've never
claimed to be good role models like
don't come to them like one of your kids
to learn from them that's not who they
are that's not what they want to be
they've never branded themselves that
way to like I'm so done with people just
like hurling feminism against the
Kardashians like you want a feminism six
women literally all women who started
their own business are like the richest
[ __ ] in the world and like totally
owned Hollywood like please I'm so done
with being like their anti-feminist no
they're not and you know what's
anti-feminist is bringing other women
down jameelah and you want okay you want
a hawk suppress it okay great don't buy
it
dumpy Jamila but also what's wrong with
wanting to like have a flat stomach and
wanting to lose weight that doesn't mean
you can't play with your kids no totally
and also if my appetite is suppressed
I'm not thinking about how hungry I am
and then I can focus on my kids no one
it's like either way I don't want to eat
a lot so at least if I haven't ate since
I'm not thinking about how hungry I am
no look I'm you know me I'm like all
about like it's like positivity
acceptance blahblahblah like when did it
become a bad thing to want to be skinny
or to get to want to go on a diet like
this like that's so crazy it's a
personal choice it's like at the very
like at the surface level what she's
saying is insulting to people who like
want to lose weight and want to better
themselves on a bigger grander level
like stop [ __ ] putting down the
Kardashians but just because you don't
want a flat tummy Valley no totally I'm
just I'm so done and I'm so not here for
this Olympic dashians like they are
everything like I don't like literally
like I have a career because of a
Kardashian it's like so much of like
girl with no job is based off I'm just
like talking about them and there are so
many people who could say that there are
so many people who literally have a job
because of their Kardashians like they
create culture and like [ __ ] you
seriously [ __ ] you I'm done with the I
will not have any Kardashian criticism
on my show okay but just before we shine
the Kardashian criticism I'm just gonna
read some tweets just to show you what
other people are saying okay some
negative tweets
someone said can't believe this is
actually real someone else what kind of
mother would advertise appetite
suppressants Jesus Christ their money
hungry no respect someone else I hope
this isn't real this woman has far too
much influence over young girls and
seems incapable of using it in a
positive way someone else as a mother
this terrifies me as a
this boils my blood discussing no wonder
people struggle so much when blank like
this is rammed down your throat
she wants to wobble her head the blank
idiot calls herself a role model another
one by Pierce Morgan I've just read
about it very disturbing there's
absolutely nothing disturbing about
wanting to go done and like by the way
flat tummy tea like is an appetite
suppressant so why is there now yeah cuz
it's a lollipop everyone is so full of
[ __ ] like so flirty like the whole every
the whole Instagram ecosystem revolves
around flat tummy tea you don't like
that it's a lollipop now yeah I wasn't
is it appetite suppressant so why are
people now upset because it's in
lollipop form or they just didn't
realize the tea was also a suppressant
no I really hope Jameela Jamil is is
coming after Weight Watchers future
system so from South Beach side of
course even um you know the the key
though no what's that diet gluten free
vegans you're suppressing after your
left you're not eating everything that
you can you're not stuffing your face
all the time I don't really think that
you should be taking on this cause I'm
joy I'm done with like everyone being
upset about everything you know what
and like the feminists are taking it too
far here ready you want to be fat you
fat you want to be skinny be skinny do
whatever the hell you want eat what you
want til you want do what you want for a
living endorse whatever you want on
Instagram and I accept it because we're
all equal and you can do whatever the
[ __ ] you want and I don't care anymore
okay like everyone being upset about
everything is like are you tired
I'm not upset anymore like I just let go
I'd like this weight has been lifted off
my shoulders because I'm done like I'm
done caring about things I'm done
getting upset over what people do and
say like I'm my own person I'm gonna eat
what I want feel but I won't be what I
want and that's good enough for me I
can't be influenced anymore okay
I'm stronger than that well honestly I'm
influenced by this because I think I'm
gonna buy a lollipop because this is an
amazing ad good job Kim yes she'll talk
you look like and I literally thought
I'd literally saw it and I was like oh
my god I am like a kid defender I mean
Kim Stan like I'm gonna start fighting
with people on Twitter but it's like if
she wants to do something that I really
didn't agree with I'd be happy to say
like I don't agree with this yeah I
wouldn't luckily that hasn't had a
defender to the death
can you blindly defend her I do okay
this next story is so weird okay so
you're gonna have to just pay attention
is this the cook thing yes oh my god so
weird the sorted photographic proof that
Christie Christie Brinkley's cheating ex
Peter Cook had a steamy five-day hookup
with the mistress who took Ramona
singers husband what the [ __ ] do you see
the pictures Claudia they're weird I
have my own theory okay so I'm gonna
read the Daily Mail books points that
pretty much have everything
steamy photos shared exclusively with
the Daily Mail show Peter Cook and Casey
Dexter at the wealthy architects
Hamptons property beauty accessory
Binkley's ex-husband Casey Dexter is
alleged mistress of Mario Lopez
/ - singer and I legs confirmed yeah
cook 59 denied rumors of an encounter
after it was reported that he flew
Dexter 36 to his home earlier this month
in one I pop Knapp cook is seen cupping
the exposed breasts of his young lover
while they pose up together in his
master bedroom close friend Ally Moore
told Daily Mail com that the two had a
sex field trip and Dexter is less than
happy at his ridiculous claim that they
never got together hmm Pierre told Casey
I'm falling for you you are so beautiful
even with no makeup and asked her to
come back and visit Moore said it's been
said Cook has a secret pathological
predilection for young women and
famously split with Christie Brinkley in
2008 after cheating with an 18 year old
okay in this guy's defense an 18 year
old and a 36 year old is they're not
there yet
in fact it's double yeah Dexter is also
known to be the mistress of Mario singer
while he was married to real housewife
Ramona Singer
okay gets around this girls like no
respect from average it's like so well
no well Peter Peter cooks not married no
but the pictures are when they were
married really that's the scandal are
you sure oh no I don't think I don't
think that he was married when these
pictures what are the pictures from like
recently so here's the thing he they
were hooking up and then he publicly
said that he never hooked up with her
and this [ __ ] got angry had her friend
ally Moore run over to the Daily Mail my
iPads being like [ __ ] up but okay she
was upset that he deny that they hooked
up this is my interpretation so she had
her friend give these pictures to the
Daily Mail and give these sordid details
that none of us need to know but now we
so like one of the photos from that's
just what I want is I think like
recently okay like this is just W can I
show the picture of her breasts no all
right go look it up in the toilets NSFW
my it's like they're taking mirror pics
like you couple mirror pics of them just
like hey is he rich and then though your
iPad died it's dead that doesn't have
any battery yes was that the last story
it was charging all day yesterday no
there was one more story you're on fifty
six here iPad I think it just needed to
restart itself it works really hard
during the show wait that is crazy and
honestly she's amazing boobs like if you
looking you go oh yeah they're nice big
fake titties yeah also like EFT I'd love
a good pair of big fake titties and this
is a nice so anyways they're taking like
a couple shots mirror pics then she's
like randomly pulls up her top and she's
not wearing a bra
he's almost looking like the plastic
surgeon who yeah he's not dating her a
baby he's like cupping it like this is
my work yeah under Gardner who is Peter
Cook besides crispy man a big-time
architect architect yeah he almost were
an architect like his Hamptons house is
not that nice and picture up in the deli
almost was a big time magazine editor
but then he went the are never the Jenna
rank got the job
so he had to pivot I am Jenna rink Big
Time magazine editor um yes so this is
just really crazy and it's crazy how
this story is like this girl did not go
cover her tracks enough because it's
clear that she really sees Soto's no of
course she's behind it she probably
broke up with her and that she's all but
her yeah and it's like [ __ ] out here
are crazy and you know if she got with
Mario singer that she doesn't have her
[ __ ] together know that she has
absolutely no standards right that would
this and the fact that we go in his name
Peter Cook Mario singer don't get it
twisted
yeah Peter Cook esteemed magazine editor
Mario disgraced househusband so I just I
think Ramona's probably laughing
somewhere it's better this is this is
the truth all the roads lead back to any
coming like it's always about Andy or
it's always about Bravo like for some
weird twisted reason everything revolves
around Provo and this is proof yeah I
think because then you can include II in
it no but like please be people are like
not nearly as cool as probably ball I
don't know the dream is a Broadway show
like the rich kids Nick well some of
them were I like them I like that I like
Morgan sorta actually like that what we
were just in the car yesterday talking
about how much you like that I know
they're good they're good they're good
but like they're nowhere near school
it's just trying to prove your point
that you're not understanding that you
know the world does revolve around Bravo
and Bravo talent is literally so supreme
even the best person on besides the
Kardashians cuz I'm chef oh my god they
have one bad Joe and everyone watches
that a cop Roth okay okay Prince Harry
and Megan Marcos bridesmaids and
pageboys reveal for the rail reading
wedding oh my god they have page choices
they're breaking from chickens can it's
gonna be there they're breaking from
tradition cuz you're really only
supposed to do family but like Megan's
like [ __ ] up family like they couldn't
you know produce a couple kids I mean
now she's using some of her friends kids
it's all so weird
stop tryna make it seem like they're
that's cool progressive couple but it's
like they couldn't find any kids that
are related to Megan so they had to use
other people's kids this wedding is a
train wreck
I'm so sorry Ben and I like I went on
The Daily Mail like to look for stories
for this morning and every single story
it's about Megan Marco and like good for
her this is what she wanted for her but
this is a like we're three days out from
the wedding like it it shouldn't be all
about Megan Marco like this wedding is
gonna give this country you know a few
more years of economic sustainability
right so like let's keep it to me it's
all part of the Machine and though it is
and so are we
and we're attributor and we're happy to
for do our part yeah
throw a wedding is just three days away
and on Wednesday Kensington Palace
revealed the members of Prince Harry and
Megan Marcos wedding party as previously
announced Prince William will serve as
his brother's best man but Megan will
not have a maid of honor quote she's a
very close-knit circle of friends and
she didn't want to choose one over
another okay so she has no friends yeah
all have been actively involved in
helping her prepare for the day and
we'll be there in the days beforehand
she's very happy to have their support
oh my god like what is Mike and Marco
doing right this minute no I know I
think she's asleep at the gym like
punching oh yeah a punching bag with
like her photo Christmas it was just the
name mark him on it I bet she's so
excited to drop the the surname Marco
and making Windsor but then
her real name is Rachel yes she's Rachel
Windsor so she what is she gonna go buy
I feel like she should go buy great
chill just because it's more of a
classic name like it's biblical
and therefore like spelled correctly
it'll be good in the Shia's Megan with
an H right and then it'll just it's more
of a royal name I agree because it goes
back centuries as opposed to like from
the day she was born and like I saw this
article on e and it's like people are
really just like struggling to make
contact these days it's like here's what
Princess Diana could have done to help I
saw that Megiddo Markel in her scandal
like maven says
Princess Diana would have protected
Megan right okay coulda woulda shoulda
she's dead you won't protect anyone from
the press especially naive Princess
Diana totally and all these things on
the side of the sidebar of e are stories
about Megan Marco let me rattle she's
really taken aback and like look at her
this small time home our girl is
literally a princess we give you a
princess okay first these are the
stories young manga marketplace queen
with childhood friends okay that's an
old-ass video it's from her like as a
four year old running around with a
crown on I can't commissioned Megan
Marco is destined to be a duchess find
out you're right royal title using our
name generator' shut up should we do it
okay we the last one is Megan Markos
family issues are bringing her and
Prince Harry closer together you don't
know that
no that's 100% untrue and Harry's like
oh god what did I get my phone and then
of course can I still get a divorce my
dad did it is that cool Megan Markos dad
Thomas's royal wedding debacle here's
what we know you guys by the way we know
nothing he was was going he wasn't going
he was gonna and I was at this moment
not going again but he could still go
hilt what is like at I think at a
certain point I think it'll be like
Friday at 12 p.m. noon if he's still in
the country then he's not going because
like he won't make the flight time was
yeah it just doesn't make sense okay we
where's my royal name generator' did you
click link I did [ __ ] clickbait
clickbait find out your royal title
using our royal name generate okay here
we go you guys what do you think I think
Jacqueline is actually pretty royal I've
got this to first take the first letter
of your first came to discover your new
identity listed as male or female or the
pronoun of your choosing okay
J mine would be Juliet C yours would be
Katherine
okay that's cute next take the first
letter of your last name to find out
your surname I'll go with sulfur and you
go with Australia Oh Oswald to the
second Juliet as well at the second okay
and Catherine Catherine Sheffield
Oh mr. Sheffield but I can shun guys
that's hardly a generator you can then
select the month you were born July July
okay Catherine Sheffield grand Oh Grand
Duchess Catherine Sheffield okay I'm
literally Kate Middleton she's the
Duchess of Cambridge I'm sorry princess
Juliet Oswald the second that's truly
the ugliest name okay but also I think I
think I can use Jacqueline instead of
Juliet because me too like Jacqueline is
very prestigious oh yeah princess
Jacqueline Oswald the second wasn't the
problem
wait okay princess Jacqueline ashtray
the second that's right oh yeah I'm Trey
that's like the Andres what's that it's
like literally the least royal name uh
wait okay let me do it with Weinreb this
okay princess Jacqueline Winthrop v
there we go thank you from Juliet and
Catherine and it's been a true pleasure
serving this morning we will see you
tomorrow morning
we are the morning toast we're live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time every weekday on YouTube so
subscribe on Facebook symmetry like us
and then we're also available in podcast
app so leave us a subscription with a 5
star review about how gorgeous and glowy
we are and how good we are at our makeup
I'm Claudia are a girl with no job and
Claud with no job so please feel free to
follow me on either account
I'm Jackie ah hey Jackie O problems
please feel free to follow me I say it
every day and it's not helping okay
we'll see you tomorrow